[Music]
anthony's in san antonio hey anthony
what's up
hey dave hey john pleasure to speak to
you both
so
quick uh background here i'm on baby
step number two me and my wife are our
household income is about 90k
um since january we've been blessed the
lord has given us good jobs we've been
able to pay about a third of our debt so
we've got about 24k paid off already
we've got about 40 remaining
years ago before we realized how bad we
were with money uh we did have a
conversation with my little sister about
going to las vegas for her 21st birthday
our hearts have changed completely we're
obviously trying to get out of debt
and
my whole family is going to vegas we did
the math we're really leaning towards
not going but at the same time it's her
21st she's only and it's probably going
to be her last 21st birthday or last
birthday ever before she gets married
she's in a very serious relationship
with a
delightful young man but
we just don't know what to do we've we
did the math it'll probably set us back
maybe a month not even a month if we
paid for this trip obviously we're done
with credit cards we're done with all
that so we're going to cash flow if we
go but we're really
leaning towards not going so what's it
called
uh probably about 900
um
and everything
if if we drive with gas prices i did the
map for that as well it maybe save us
like 30 or 50 bucks
we drive uh together tacoma
um i'm not sure
it would it seems like with the gas
prices we're spending 75 everything i
don't think you want to go not because
of money what's the other reason you
don't want to go
i i want to go
but i also
i it's just it seems like a lot with how
dedicated we've been to paying off debt
it seems like a lot of money to drop to
go do something that
my wife and i aren't even really that
pleasure i i don't know because i mean
you don't want to get out of vegas like
you don't want to go
part part of it but it's also my little
sister's birthday and my whole family's
going i feel a little bad how long are
they going to be there
they're
if my wife and i are go we're only going
for a night they're going to be there
for like thursday through sun through
monday and i'm 100
well
we would have to probably get a hotel on
the way out there as well just because
and on the way back if we drive because
plane tickets are absurd right now so we
would have to book a hotel on the drive
out there look at the hotel on the way
on the drive back and then one hotel
night in vegas
i think that you want to want to go i
think you love the idea of celebrating
your sister i don't think you want to go
to vegas
whenever i don't want to do something i
inflate how much it's going to cost
by
one and a half or two times i'm like
that's going to cost a thousand bucks
probably 500 maybe 600. when i do want
to do something really big like i need
this new thing it's like it's probably
100 bucks and it's it's way more than
that
right something tells me you don't want
to go
you want to celebrate your sister but
you don't want to do the trip
i i guess that's partly true i mean me
and my wife kind of talked about even if
we went go we would probably
not go to the clubs and do things like
that that they would want to do because
obviously we're in debt and and to be
completely honest with you that's not
our scene
we would love to go and see the shows
and things like that but but the clubs
and all that and and drinking i mean
that's not something my wife and i
really partake in yeah
um
so they're
in that and that's
my little sister yeah yeah in that sense
john's right um
the only part of this that you want to
do is celebrate your sister you don't
want to do anything that they're doing
and you don't want to go
um other than just you do want to
celebrate her and that that's because
you're a good guy i mean that you should
you should want to do that that's a good
thing so dave you can tell me when it
comes to baby steps when it comes to a
milestone like this i wouldn't have a
problem it's going to set you back 25
days on your journey if you pay cash and
go and do your thing that didn't bother
me i also doesn't bother me if you have
your set of values and say hey we're not
going to do this thing
um
i hate it when somebody gets boxed into
an either or i just don't like
is there a way to do something different
but it doesn't sound like there is here
i don't know what to tell you to do this
different yeah um
yeah and it sounds like also the rest of
the family is going to be like
the weirdos are back at home
you know
yeah yeah
that too and then we know i know in my
parents i know that if i say hey me and
claire aren't going that's not what i
said we're not we're not going dude you
we are in we're doing this dave ramsey
thing we're trying to get out of the
don't blame it on me yeah this isn't
your choice brother
this one's on you don't know when my
parents don't they'll just offer to pay
for it i know and i don't want that
either anthony
if i'm you i would go
that's me okay and dave you may say
differently i would probably go and i
like you i don't i don't go to the clubs
i'm just not that's not my thing i
wouldn't do that and i i'm a nerd i go
to bed early and um but we go and
celebrate and have the dinner and say
it's great and then we'd head out early
five nights in vegas or that's
that's a lot yeah um the other side of
it is don't blame anybody if you decide
to not go because of your values say we
don't really or we're not really
interested in going to there we'll
celebrate when she gets back uh we'll
have everybody over for dinner we're in
the middle of this thing and we're
getting out of debt and right now we
just can't do it we're just sorry and
it's okay to say either one and it's
okay to cheap out on a couple of other
things and get the 900 down to 500 um
you know with your hotel choice or
whatever else and
it's also okay if your parents want to
pay for it
if you want to go
that's okay there's nothing wrong with
that at all
i'm thinking of a parent if i'm if one
of my kids was working on something and
they're saying hey we don't want to go
because we want to hit this goal i'm
like well if you would like to go we
really want to have you
we're not going to guilt you and i'll
cover it for you if you want to come
because we really want you there that
bad
and um
that wouldn't bother me as a parent a
little bit yeah and so and and i would
hope my child could could accept that
uh but if if that you know but if they
say no we just don't then i gotta i
gotta respect their boundaries and go no
they don't wanna come okay so that's
okay and and so i mean i've been in lots
of situations like this over the years
with family um i remember sharon's
family kept you know we kept having more
and more and more and more grandkids on
that side and so buying gifts for every
stinking person got to be the federal
deficit in the year
the year we went broke i just rolled
into sharon's parents house and sharon
wasn't even happy with me but i'm like
hey we can't do this we don't need money
uh we can draw names yes we'll draw
we'll buy for kids that are under five
and we're drawing names for the rest of
you goops
and uh
one of the other sisters goes well
finally somebody said it let's do it you
know but i was everybody's all worried
that dave was about to break the thing
that the family tradition was about oh
it's all gonna go down in flames because
of dave but it turned out okay and now
they've drawn names for 20 30 years now
you know so